vielen dank auch jetzt versucht uns die
heute show auch noch weihnachten mit
carolin und martin hallo liebe halter
die weihnachtszeit und die immer gleiche
frage was kann man eigentlich noch guten
gewissens schenken ja ich schenk dir
wieder einen sandwich toaster ich hasse
dich du bist schwein liebe zuschauer es
ist wirklich schwierig unser deutsches
weihnachten funktionierten leider nur
mit ausbeutung und sklaverei stimmt
nehmen wir mal schokolade dürfte man
eigentlich gar nicht essen richtig weil
cacau vor allem in afrika unter
unmenschlichen bedingungen und oft von
kindern geerntet wird
andererseits was willst du machen waren
und denen da geld geben oder hier
gummibärchen das gleiche problem die
gummibärchen in ruhig werden noch fetter
damit gummibärchen schön glänzen wird in
brasilien ein spezielles palmen wachs
geerntet auch von besseren sklaven ich
frage mich was die eltern dieser kinder
wohl denken wenn sie wüssten dass die
süßigkeiten ihrer kia spuren von
sklavenarbeit enthalten
bei den roten habe ich das auch ob
gedacht die schmeckt ist total scheiße
wie es auch nicht viel besser
die klamotten die ich hier immer
schenken muss werden alle irgendwo in
asien genäht oder das smartphone mit dem
sie unterm tisch hindert wenn wir unsere
ganz fressen ja nächste ich mag das
nicht du [ __ ] da ist kobalt drin
das wird von kindern im kongo aus der
erde gekratzt partner auf do
liebe zuschauer
es ist das fest der liebe wir müssen uns
nur bewusst machen was andere für unser
weihnachten erleiden und nicht nur in
der dritten welt
auch bei uns hier carus mutter wird von
einer pflegekraft aus der ukraine
betreut hält appel und ein ei 24 stunden
am tag verstehst komplett gegen
deutsches arbeitsrecht
aber wir sind so froh dass wir ihn haben
gerade jetzt an weihnachten
ich würde die feiertagen doch lieber
euch verbringen und dann kann die
ihrigen auto ihre familie
es ist leider komplett demenz
jetzt präsentiert deutlichere auf
merkmale noch nie ein thema kurz und
martin kemp